is
good afternoon everyone my name is david
bob i serve as director of the
hillsdale college allen p kirby jr
center for constitutional studies and
citizenship
it's great to see all of you today and
to welcome our online audience who's
joining us
coast to coast as we're webcasting this
first principles
on first friday's event today we're
really uh thrilled to have
with us uh kirby center distinguished
fellow
and former member of congress the
honorable john
shatig he'll be introduced more formally
in
in a few minutes but i wanted to say
that it's been a tremendous pleasure to
come to know him
and to see having observed
throughout the course of of his career
what a
impressive difference he made mr
shattuck was elected
in the freshman class
of 1994 and today he's going to relate a
little bit about
lessons that we might learn from that
104th congress
but even more how we can begin to make
because it certainly is a process that
is going to take some time
how we can bring congress into
accountability
with the constitution of the united
states that is a task for which mr
shattuck
is eminently suited as it was his
efforts through a number of pieces of
legislation but also
day-to-day interaction with his
colleagues to
stand for principled limited
government and as we have gone around
meeting with various members of
especially the freshman class it's been
really
uh most insightful to see how mr
shattuck can relate to these members
there's a lot of them they're looking
for guidance they're looking for
ideas they're looking for a sense of how
they can begin to resist
those pressures on them that have for so
long now
shifted this country in a very different
direction from that of the american
founding
but what's great is our speaker today
has a very clear sense of how that can
be done and he's going to sketch for us
some
some thoughts on that topic we're really
pleased that he has joined us and that
he has joined hillsdale college as a
distinguished fellow with the kirby
center
as i mentioned today today uh and only
for the second time we are
live webcasting this event so if you're
watching us
from the comfort of your home or office
or anywhere else around the country
and wish to participate in this forum by
asking a question
we'd ask that you email that question to
us at first
fridays first fridays plural at
hillsdale.edu
the kirby center as some of you now know
since we've been doing this lecture
series since december of 2008
marks an extension of the college
through teaching
the enduring principles of the
declaration of independence and the
constitution
we seek to inspire citizens to defend
those principles
you can find out more about our mission
and our programs
on our website at the kirbycenter.org
and we invite all of you to
uh attend some of the other events that
we're going to be holding
uh this summer among them an event on
june the 10th a gathering uh welcoming
our
students hillsdale college has for 40
years
now been sending undergraduate students
to washington dc
we like to joke at the college that this
is a study abroad program
coming from hillsdale michigan it's a
very different thing and our purpose in
sending them to washington is not
to make them cogs in the in the
administrative state but rather to
to give them a very different sense of
and a continuation of their liberal
education that they receive on campus
this summer we have some 40 hillsdale
college students who are in washington
dc
and about 10 of those are interning with
the kirby center others are interning at
various think tanks
congressional offices and media outlets
around the
city one of those students is hillsdale
college junior
sophie carr a politics and
sorry she's majoring in political
economy and history
hails from minnesota she's serving an
internship at the kirby center
and will per hillsdale's tradition now
introduce our speaker today
sophie
mr john shattuck was elected u.s
representative from arizona's 3rd
congressional district in 1994.
he served eight terms and was chairman
of the conservative house republican
study committee
shattuck is a veteran of the arizona air
national guard
and served as a special assistant
attorney general in arizona
a graduate of the university of arizona
where he also
received a law degree he was the
founding director of the goldwater
institute for public policy
he now serves as a distinguished fellow
with the hillsdale college kirby center
today he will be speaking on the timely
and pressing topic
making congress accountable to the
constitution
please join me in welcoming mr john
shattuck
good afternoon and thank you very much
for that kind introduction sophie
i want to thank hillsdale college i want
to thank
dr larry arn and dr david bob
and i especially want to thank the kirby
center for constitutional
studies for making this opportunity
available to me it is one that's near
and dear to my heart
but it is a daunting one the issue of
making congress accountable to the
constitution
is one that i think is going to require
a
vast amount of work and i would suggest
quite a bit of time
it cannot be done overnight i want to
begin by telling uh
just a quick little story sometimes we
get this notion that well
it doesn't matter this is a lost cause
there isn't any hope
to try to bring the nation all the way
back to the founding principles and get
it to where
we know it should be and where the
founders intended it as i listened to
david make his remarks
it reminded me of a story that points
out that
quite frankly that's not true that as a
matter of fact
we have it within our power and the
story is one that
i happen to just tell over at the
capitol because i was giving a brief
tour
to some friends who were visiting from
arizona and i took them out on a balcony
outside the speaker's office
and i explained the story and and i
think they got a kick out of it
you will see the connection because it
tells the fact
or it tells the the makes the point of
how
with concentrated effort and the right
number of people committed to the cause
you can do
just about anything it turns out that
when
i got elected in 1994 the republican
revolution arrived in washington
we all got our committee assignments and
i'll talk a little bit about the
corrupting process of getting committee
assignments
later in my remarks but we all went
about our tasks
and it was a it was a large freshman
class you might recall i believe there
were 74 republicans in the freshman
class maybe 73
not quite as big as the current freshman
class but in some ways maybe more
boisterous
than the current freshman class and i'd
like to see the current freshman class
get a little more boisterous myself
but one of the members of our class was
a gentleman named mark newman from
wisconsin
and mark was a self-made millionaire
he had done well in the home building
industry and because he was a numbers
guy
he had been assigned to the
appropriations committee and he had
worked away on the appropriations
committee but
like all freshmen he came here filled
with them and vigor and the belief that
we were going to reform washington and
that
that's what we were about we were going
to change washington indeed we were not
going to let washington change us
well being a numbers expert mark was
forever
kind of digging into the numbers as the
appropriations bills went through the
process
and finding where the staff was wrong or
where the chairman
was wrong or where we were spending much
more than mark
as a member of the freshman class of
1994 thought we ought to
and he was forever digging in the
chairman's shorts and kind of saying
this isn't right and we're spending too
much and this bill is spending too much
and this bill sets the level too high
and he was a constant frustration to the
then
chairman of the appropriations committee
a gentleman you may recall by the name
of bob livingston
well on one particular occasion mark
showed up at a committee meeting had all
his notes they
were to advance a bill that day mark
started picking the bill apart
now this is a republican controlled
appropriations committee
it had a republican chairman and mark
was of course a republican
and he was picking apart the bill and he
was pointing out its flaws and how it
spent too much
and finally the commitment of a vote
came and uh mark cast his vote and he
voted against the bill
and finally uh chairman livingston just
blew up he'd had it he turned to the
newman and he said
that's it i can't take it anymore you're
off the committee
and so with one fell swoop our colleague
in the freshman class mark newman
had been kicked off of his main
committee of assignment
well word of that story flashed through
the freshman class like
lightning it wasn't i'll bet you 10
minutes before every freshman had heard
the story
even if you were sitting in a committee
room somewhere halfway across the
capitol
somebody walked in even though this was
in the days before blackberries
and said hey did you hear what happened
to mark newman well
within less than an hour the class met
and sat down and said well what are we
going to do and it was agreed that we
simply couldn't stand by and tolerate
this because we'd all kind of said to
ourselves oh my gosh
if bob livingston can kick mark newman
off of the appropriations committee
then gosh my chairman could kick me off
of my committee
so very quickly thereafter a call was
placed to the speaker's office and a
group of three of us were delegated to
go sit down with a speaker and discuss
this particular issue so
we did and the reason it comes to mind
is that we did so it was a nice day like
today was beautiful outside
and we met with the speaker on the
balcony that looks down the mall
and it's a spectacular place if you've
ever been there i urge you to go someday
if you can
you can not only look down the mall but
you can look down pennsylvania avenue
and but for the trees you could see the
white house and we sat down
three of us representing the freshman
class and turned to uh
newt and said mr speaker um this is not
acceptable to our class
and if you do not resolve it by the time
the sun sits today
to mr newman's uh satisfaction
we the members of the freshman class of
1994 make no guarantee that you will be
speaker of the house tomorrow
well newt could count uh and you
discovered that in
this nation the way founding fathers
intended it counting matters
and it was quite true that we had made
we had created
uh the republican majority through our
74 freshmen
and if we had decided that night that
newt had not satisfactorily fixed this
problem
then the next morning we could have sat
down with the blue dogs or a coalition
of democrats and said okay
let's negotiate who the next speaker is
well that was not lost on us but it was
not lost on newt and before the sun set
the matter was resolved to mark newman's
satisfaction
the reason i say that to you is because
i'm going to suggest two ways in which
we can hold congress accountable of the
constitution in my remarks
one of them is procedural but the more
important one is people
it really is you and i being engaged
it's doing what
uh the kirby center and hillsdale
college are doing
the founders clearly did intend the
congress to be
accountable but they also intended to
live by the constitution
i asked uh that you all be given a copy
of this
uh story or the brief story of davey
crockett david bob assured me that
people who come to kirby center events
would already be familiar with the story
uh and i see some nodding heads and many
of you are but it's one we should recall
i think
over and over again it's the famous
story of
a tragedy that befalls i believe a
family out in
on the far side of the city where there
had been a fire in
georgetown and the congress is on the
verge of appropriating some money to
help
the widow and davy crockett stands up
and relates the story and the story had
to do with when he had been campaigning
during a previous campaign year
and had been called aside by a
constituent who said
you have no authority to do what you
propose to do when you
give away money and you clearly don't
understand the constitution and for that
reason i won't vote for you again
and the story is worth rereading it
details of how davey cocker
thought through the issue and recognized
that of course the constituent was quite
right
um and that there was no authority for
what the congress was proposing to do
and he rose on the floor of the house
and gave a and commanding speech
at a point when congress is about to do
something clearly outside the
constitution
and the overwhelming vote was going to
be in favor of that legislation and davy
crockett stopped it
but he stopped it in part because of
this issue
the people had held him as a congressman
accountable to the constitution and he
had stood and led his colleagues
and said to them that they needed to
recognize their obligation to the
constitution
so uh what more can we do how do we
achieve this
uh daunting task of holding a congress
which has
drifted astray from the constitution
accountable to it
one of course is public awareness that
we have in fact drifted away from
the fundamental teachings of the
constitution
i think some of you may know the story
that during the health care debate
last year a member of congress a
long long long term member of congress
was confronted at an event i believe on
the west coast he was a west coast
congressman from california
he was asked well congressman if you
the federal government you the congress
can compel us
the citizens to buy a health insurance
policy that we don't want
either because we don't like that policy
or perhaps because we don't even like
allopathic medicine we believe in
naturopathic medicine
are there any limits on what you the
congress can do
and it's been widely reported that this
congressman thought for a moment and
responded pretty quickly to say no
there's literally nothing we can't do
that's at least one story where
i think it pretty clearly illustrates
very quickly uh how far
adrift we are from the constitution
there's one more i like to tell
it also comes from the healthcare arena
where i've spent a fair amount of my
time
let me stop right here and just say i'm
going to try to tell this story or make
my points
kind of as a pragmatic politician
because that's where my experience is
and if we want to get into uh kind of
how we take this process back i think
it's going to involve a lot of pragmatic
politics
you know in the health care debate right
now going on and if you've read any of
the cases that are being argued
the justification being given by the
government
for compelling us for being able to
compel us all
to buy a health insurance policy compel
us to spend our money to buy a private
sector product
is that and the government argues this
in their briefs
that uninsured individuals
sitting in their homes doing nothing
affect interstate commerce well how do
they affect
interstate commerce well the government
argues that they affect the interstate
commerce because the mere
decision not to buy health insurance
shifts costs from that individual
to the rest of society well now think
about that for a moment
you're sitting in your home you're doing
absolutely nothing but
say reading the federalist papers as you
should be
and you've chosen not to buy any health
insurance
and some lawyer for the federal
government says you are shifting costs
in the health care system and since
you're shifting costs that affects or
that impacts interstate commerce
it substantially infects interstate
commerce and therefore
in the exercise of the commerce clause
the federal government can reach out to
you
sitting on your couch in your living
room reading the federalist papers and
say
get up and go buy a health insurance
policy that we have dictated the
contents of
and when you've done that we promise we
won't find you well
in its brief uh making this argument
that you have shifted costs
it caused me to think for at least a
moment and say now wait a minute how did
how did you shift costs well uh
let's think it through just one one more
step let's say you got up on the couch
you walk to the nearest hospital you
presented yourself at the front door you
held out your arm and said look it's
broken
set it and give the bill to david bob
he's a nice uh successful young
businessman he clearly can pay this bill
you think the hospital would do that i
suspect they wouldn't do that
not hardly but nonetheless that's what
the government
argues the government might say well
we're not gonna quite do it that way
uh we're gonna say that when you got up
out of your couch and went to the
uh hospital and held out your arm and
said it's broken and said please fix it
and oh by the way send the bill to david
bob what you really did is send the bill
to david bob's insurance company
but the reality is you don't shift any
costs
so unfortunately in his decision
in the florida case judge henson says
vincent says
absolutely not your decision to sit in
your home in your on your couch
and read the federalist papers or do
whatever else you choose to do
doesn't shift any costs at all but why
did the government have to go there
because the government wanted to impose
a penalty on you
he wanted to be able to force you to buy
a health insurance policy
that you didn't uh in fact want because
it claimed that you were shifting this
cost
but let's dig a little bit deeper
because judge vincent in his opinion
didn't dig
any deeper into the why are costs being
shifted
this is a hot debate in the briefs if
you read them going back and forth
and the answer is costs are in fact
being shifted
but why are they being shifted because i
think if you ask the question of why
they're being shifted
you discover why the government in fact
is the last entity in the world that
ought to be able to impose the penalty
it's chosen which is to force us to buy
a health insurance policy
and let me explain the why as a society
we've decided long ago that nobody
should go without health care we also
decided that in the society nobody
should go without at least basic health
care but also without basic food
or without basic shelter and so years
ago when i was a kid growing up
if someone who became ill in phoenix
arizona
did not have the money to be able to go
to a hospital and get an
arm set if it was broken we said
not to worry about that we as a society
have made a societal decision that you
shouldn't leave your
arm on set and so the thing that you did
if you couldn't pay the bill is you went
to a public hospital
in phoenix arizona you went to maricopa
county hospital
and a doctor there set your arm and
that doctor was compensated by public
money
now what are how do we get if that was
true
then how did you get to where we are now
and the answer is that in the late
late 1980s the united states congress
by the way at the behest of the same
congressman who said there are no limits
on the power of the federal congress
anymore
past the law call them tala now amtala
is the emergency
medical treatment and active labor act
and amtala says
that if you're a hospital in america
or you're a doctor working at a hospital
in america and somebody presents
at that hospital and has a broken arm
you must set their arm for free
okay i'm i'm fine with that because
that's society's decision that
those amongst us shouldn't have to do
without basic health care
but guess what the government then did
the government said and oh by the way
you're going to be compelled to do that
if you're a hospital that has an
emergency room
and accept medicare and oh by the way
we're not going to pay you everyone in
this room i think knows
that in america today you can walk into
any hospital you choose
and if you don't have the resources you
get free medical care
but not many people realize that nobody
pays for the federal government doesn't
pay for that health care anymore
the federal government doesn't write a
check the local county government
doesn't write a check
the local state government writes a
check the government just orders
doctors and hospitals to do that now
imagine for just a moment
if we ordered grocery stores we said you
know what there's some people in this
country who
don't have food so we're just going to
issue an order that says if you own
a grocery store or if you own a ranch or
if you own
a farm and you raise corn and a certain
number of people present themselves
for food you must give it to them
funny thing we don't do that instead we
created a program called food stamps
and that program provides food to those
in need and housing the same is true but
in health care
we chose to cut the corner how did we
get into such
a deep problem as led us to the passage
of obamacare
the answer is we ignored the
constitution and i think everybody in
the room knows it here's how we ignored
the constitution
this little document has an amendment
fifth amendment
many of us know it we talk about it a
lot in the criminal area because it says
you cannot
be compelled to be a witness against
yourself but the last clause of the
fifth amendment says
nor shall private property be
taken for public use without just
compensation
guess what where in the world are
america's hospitals and doctors
i got a clue none of them has ever read
the dang fifth amendment
because the fifth amendment says no
property
shall be taken for public use without
just compensation
and yet under amtala we are saying to
every hospital in america
you must deliver care to anyone who
presents themselves
even if they don't have an insurance
policy that's property
you must give it to people public in the
society so it's
the taking of property for public use
and guess what when the congress passed
this bill it said
by the way we're not going to compensate
you it's not we're not going to give you
just compensation
which is one of the debates under the
law it's not whether or not this was a
good public purpose
we're not going to give you a dime we're
going to force you under mtallah to
provide free health care
i would suggest that the reason
that we are hap that we got into the
debate over obamacare
and the reason that the government wants
to
go to that kind of a system but the
reason it says that
the justification for the commerce
clause saying
that we can force you to buy a health
insurance policy you don't want
is cost shifting caused by
the very federal government that now
says to you it's going to take your
freedom
to make your own personal decision on
whether to buy that insurance policy
a different insurance policy or no
policy at all because
if amtala either didn't exist and
hospitals could turn you away and send
you to a public hospital
there would be no cost shifting if
alternatively the federal government
hadn't ignored the last clause of the
fifth amendment and recognized that when
it orders hospitals to give away free
health care
it must also provide just compensation
then there would be no cost shifting if
there were no cost shifting
then there would be a no impact on
commerce and in point of fact
there would be no justification for the
government to order you to buy a health
insurance policy you don't want
all that is to say what i think all of
it is to make the point that
when we ignore things like this
constitution
and the fifth amendment or when we let
the congress ignore them
in passing a law like amtala which
clearly is
an unconstitutional taking under the
fifth amendment then
we're in pretty deep trouble as a
society indeed i would argue that
the congress in this nation today is
pretty well unhinged from the
constitution
so the topic is how do we do something
about it and i have as i mentioned
earlier two suggestions
the first of them is a procedural
suggestion and that is
there are procedural reforms that we can
enact and some that we already have
we have for since the founding said to
members of congress
that you must take an oath of office and
that oath of office
compels you to swear allegiance to the
constitution
unfortunately uh between the united
states supreme court and the
greed or avarice of the federal
government and seeking more and more
power
that oath hasn't been enough this year i
am very encouraged
that speaker john boehner took one step
further
and required the united states congress
on it the day it was sworn in to read
the constitution that's at least a
beginning but there's one more point
that they did this year
there was something i campaigned on in
1994. in 1994 i told
my constituents that i intended to
introduce when i got here
a law that would say that every member
of the congress
house or senate who introduces a piece
of legislation
must cite in the first section of that
piece of legislation
the specific enumerated power
set forth in the u.s constitution that
grants
the federal government the authority to
do whatever it is
that has proposed to be done in that
particular bill if you go back and look
at each piece of legislation that i
introduced in my 16 years in congress
i'm
pleased to say that we in fact did
insert a constitutional justification in
every single one of them
but this is one of those reforms that
required me to leave congress
before it got accomplished because what
happened this year is
when i retired from congress john
boehner and others in the united states
house including
scott garrett from new jersey and
congressman bishop from utah
insisted that the bill i had introduced
as the enumerated powers act
become a part of the rules of the us
house and so it is true today
that if you as a member of the u.s house
sadly not the senate yet
introduce or seek to introduce a bill in
the u.s house and you take it up to the
clerk and you offer to the clerk
and you do not proffer at the same time
a separate piece of paper
that sets forth the constitutional
justification
for that bill the clerk will simply hand
it back to you
or if you drop it in the box and leave
the clerk will send it
back to you which i think is a
tremendous first step the law of the
house today is or the rules the house
today say
you must file a constitutional
justification an identification of which
enumerated power
authorizes the federal government and
the us congress to enact legislation in
that area
a funny story about that when i first
went to introduce that bill
um it was during the gingrich revolution
i believe the chairman of the judiciary
committee at the time was henry hyde
i know the chairman of the constitution
subcommittee
at the time was charles kennedy who i
believe is now
if not the chief justice at least a
justice
of the florida supreme court and yet
when i brought the bill in
and went to take it to them to say look
will you please hold a hearing on this
bill
i met with a young staffer who looked at
me and said congressman do you have any
idea what this would do
and i said well i think i do
and this young lady was quite perplexed
she said well
gosh if i think back about it we
reauthorized lots of existing programs
and
i'm not sure i could think up a
constitutional justification
for many of those programs and i said
well
i'm really sorry to hear that but i
think that makes the point for why
it ought to be enacted into law long
story short
she killed it uh it remained uh i
introduced it every
session of congress that i was in when
my good friends tom coburn and jim
demint left the house and had the
a good sense to go to the united states
senate uh each of them took it over
there and they introduced it on the
senate side
and it continues to move forward but it
is a at least a part
of the procedures of the house and i
hope someday becomes a part
of the procedures as well so one of the
things we can do
are procedural reforms or strict
reforms of that type i would suggest to
you that more importantly however
are human reforms it is having an
engaged
and importantly and educated electorate
that remains deeply involved in the
process and i want to conclude my marks
fairly quickly here but
let me just talk about that point and
let me try to illustrate it with
some quick stories there simply is no
substitute for what is happening here
at the kirby center there simply is no
substitute
for what is happening at the campus of
hillsdale college
and there simply is no substitute for
what is happening
at tea party meetings across the country
the bottom line answer is
if we are to hold the united states
congress accountable to the constitution
we must a recognize the teachings of the
constitution
ourselves and b we must be prepared to
be very engaged
let me illustrate that with a couple of
quick stories when i got elected in 1994
i came to washington and i was a part of
the revolution and i genuinely believed
that
everybody here had the same idea of
reform as i did after all
we had the contract with america we knew
where we wanted to go
we knew we were going to restrain the
growth of government we were going to
have it tax less spend less and
interfere in people's lives less
and by gosh we were going to change
washington
guess what every freshman class
certainly every large freshman class
maybe every small freshman class
maybe every freshman who at least came
here out of a drive
of principle believes exactly that the
day they first arrive in washington
but i want to tell you a story it's
pretty hard
place to do that job when i first ran
for congress i put together a list of my
dad's friends my father had run as
some of you may know barry goldwater's
first campaign for the united states
senate
he had run senator goldwater's
subsequent senate campaigns the first
time i had come to washington was to
visit my dad living in the jefferson
hotel running
a part of the goldwater for president
campaign
first time i ever went to san francisco
was to go to the cal palace and see the
64 convention
but what i discovered when i got here
well i put together this list of my
dad's friends
one of them was an undersecretary of
agriculture under
president reagan named john norton and i
went to john norton and said i'm going
to run for john kyle's seat if john kyle
runs for the u.s senate and he said
that's fantastic he came across the
table and shook my hand and said i'll
help you
but then he sat down and over the course
of the lunch hour where we chatted he
said john you need to understand
there is no place on the face of the
earth where the pressure to go along
to get along is greater than in
washington dc
and if we are to hold members of
congress accountable the constitution
each of us not only needs to understand
the constitution
and what we are seeking to hold them
accountable to we need to understand
the the pressures that come to bear on
the people that come to this town
with good intentions we came back here
as a class in 1994 with the idea of
changing
everything we were going to end uh
smoke-filled rooms we were going to end
back room deals we were going to end the
process whereby
powerful members of congress can direct
spending to benefit themselves uh
personally or in some other way
inconsistent with
the intent of the founders and oh wow
did we have an education as many of you
know and i think his history was
has pretty well written rather than
changing washington
the class of 1994 over a period of time
got to where it allowed
washington to change it we made a lot of
good progress and i'm proud of a lot of
what we did but
by some of the things i think they're
worth noting and i tell lots of
audiences this
uh we said in the contract with america
that we were going to restore the bonds
of trust
between the american people and united
states congress and that produced bob
ney
uh it produced duke cunningham and it
produced
jack abramoff it seems to me that was
not the establishment of the bonzo trust
but what i want to say to you is rather
than being angry at those freshman class
when they come and meet that kind of
pressure you need to understand the
pressure
we as a society need to understand that
pressure and we need to make
them understand we know the pressure new
members of congress come under
to go to get along to get along when
they get here you see when they get here
they discover
oh those people back home they elected
me but if i want to advance my career
here
well then i've got to become a reliable
vote i've got to make my sub committee
chairman her
happy or i don't get my bill heard or my
full committee chairman happy
or i don't get my bill heard i've got to
make the leadership happy
or i don't get the committee assignment
i desperately want
and for us to be naive about some of
those procedural things
i think means we can't hope to achieve
the goal we want
and the answer again i would suggest to
you is that as each freshman class comes
they come with high ideals and strong
beliefs but they come into a system
that begins to say to them go along to
get along do what you're told
comport to to the norm in washington
because that's how you advance your
career
one of the things i like to do is i'd
like to get the freshmen together and
say hey stop
it may look to you when you arrive in
this town
that your future or your career is
controlled by those people above you
whether it's the speaker the majority
leader the whip your committee chair and
others
and they have some control the reality
is you better remember your boss your
bosses
are the 600 000 people that sent you
here and
that's where you're supposed to be
accountable and if you remain
accountable to and think about the
people who elected you
you'll do just fine here let's tell one
more funny story
and then conclude and hopefully take
questions when we got here we had
written the contract with america
uh in that day they brought all the
freshmen in we all signed it it was a
big deal
shortly into our term uh the leadership
decided to put on the floor of the house
and trust me we did a lot of great
things we passed the shays act we did
some great things
but leadership decided to put on the
floor a version of the balanced budget
amendment
that was different than the one in the
contract with america
well not unlike the story i told you
about mark newman our class the freshman
class the true reformer said
wait you can't do that and i was always
want to get these kinds of jobs they
said john
you need to go tell dick army that the
freshman class won't support
that version of the balanced budget
amendment after all we'd made the
promise
i don't know if you've ever seen the
life commercial that had to do with
mikey likes it
i was mikey of the freshman class i got
to do those things so
i went off i made an appointment with
dick armey i went off to see him in his
office he was
newly inc and sconced in that office and
i went in and we sat down and it started
with a
pleasant little chat back and forth
what's it like being a freshman are you
enjoying things you know
we're going back and forth how do you
think things are going it's very
pleasant after a few minutes mrs army
came into the room and said
oh boys don't let me bother you i'm just
going to be putting some things up she
was decorating
the majority leader's office and i
thought well that's very nice
and ultimately i said you know uh mr
majority leader i came here for a reason
i came here to explain to you
that we have a problem oh really what's
that well the conversation starts to go
like this i say
the freshman class simply will not
tolerate and doesn't agree with
leadership's decision to put on the
floor a version of the balanced budget
amendment different than that
which was in the contract with america
we've given our word
it's important to us to keep our word
we're connected closely to the people
back home they just set us here they
expect us to live up to our word
we got to do that and dick a bright
scholar himself solid conservatives said
well john you know that's all well and
good but
he began to explain to me why it was
impossible and we just simply could not
put
the version of the balanced budget
amendment on the floor that had been in
the contract with america
well i said you better he said we can't
i said you better
he said we can't the argument got more
and more intense and finally dick and i
are just
short of yelling at each other at full
throttle
and mrs army comes over and taps dick on
the shoulder and says uh
i think i'll step outside
because it'll become a little too
intense i would suggest to you that if
in fact
we as a nation are going to return to
the founding principles if indeed we are
going to
make congress accountable to this it's
going to get a little bit like the
conversation dick armey and i had
and that is to say it's going to get a
little hot but i think it's worth doing
and i
so very much appreciate the opportunity
to be able to speak with you today and
would be happy to answer any of your
questions
yes sir thank you
sir thank you for your service um
my question is you've talked eloquently
about the gridlock
here and then that structure that that
freshmen have to deal with
but my my question is
how do we how do i as a citizen
i understand i need to work in a
precinct locally i need to
to call and write when i have a specific
concern
but are there things that we can do as
tea party groups are there things we can
do as individuals
to overcome the lobbyists influence
to overcome the the party influence
and help help our
congress people and our senators to
remember that we're standing there
ready to pull the lever the next time
they go to the polls
there is absolutely uh not only is there
something you can do or things you can
do there are things
that you absolutely must do indeed we
absolutely must do
if we already have any hope of returning
this nation to what i think the founders
intended
um it really
spans the panoply one of the things that
i used to tell people in my early term
in congress is that news travels to
arizona
by covered wagon and what i meant by
that
is that in those days kind of heady days
of
a freshman class determined to change
this city and everything about it
doing battle day to day quite frankly
with our own leadership
telling them again and again and again
they weren't going far enough
i would be engaged in those battles and
i would go home
and i'd get off the plane and i'd meet
my wife
and she she was you know a loving spouse
and had been engaged in my campaign to
get involved and was an informed person
and out across america those fights were
subrosa nobody knew a thing she didn't
have a clue
and not only did she not have a clue she
had a a little bit of a clue compared to
the
people in the society but quite frankly
almost nobody knew
and it goes on and the answer is you you
really
a you have to stay very informed and
that's becoming
phenomenally easier than it was and when
i was a kid in
growing up and barry goldwater ran for
the son of the first time in those days
senators and house members i think
pretty much would fly to washington in
january
and fly back home in june and they'd be
gone from here in the summertime
so you wouldn't see him for months at a
time today we have
members go home every single weekend we
have the internet we have blogs we have
that vast amount of information
and yet the very same thing goes on and
i'm going to relate a story that'll
probably get me in a little bit of
trouble but it's a true story and
the truth that they say in the law is a
perfect defense
you may recall that during the cr debate
this year
uh the initial demand by republicans
was that we wanted a hundred billion
dollars in cuts
by gosh we want a hundred billion
dollars in cuts well
some discussion went back and forth and
said well no that that actually that
number 100 billion
came out of the pledge to america and
that pledge to america was for a full
year's
spending and we're only talking about
the continuing resolution which was just
the finish of this year's spending
because the democrats oh by the way
hadn't passed a budget or any spending
bills
so we scaled it back and we said let's
go with a number and let's make it 67
billion or 61 billion somewhere in that
vicinity
as we all know the negotiations began
and at the end of the day we got 38
billion
now i don't know i get it used to be
that you'd say well do you remember
where you were when john f kennedy was
assassinated
and everybody could say i don't know if
you remember when where you were
when the speaker came forward secret
banner and announced the 38 billion
dollar number but i know where i was
uh i was at a right to life dinner in
phoenix arizona
i looked at my blackberry and i thought
wow 38 billion
uh not quite what i'd hoped for but
maybe that's the best we could do maybe
that's genuine i got up the next morning
i read the paper it looked like it was a
pretty good number
i followed the number sunday morning and
monday morning and tuesday morning
and then uh what happened the truth came
out
the 38 billion is made up of uh a huge
bunch of money out of the census
that was over so we saved a bunch of
money by not spending money on a census
that we'd already finished
another huge block of that money came
out of a crime
victims fund where the money and the
fund was never tax money to begin with
they were bonds posted by criminals who
skipped the bond
or they were fines paid by criminals and
we called
that a savings in federal spending by
the way we dipped the victims
of the money that that was supposed to
go to i think you all know
that the number really at least ap came
out with a number saying
that that 38 billion dollar figure
the real savings was less than one
percent
of that figure now how does that relate
to your question
what i watched very closely was okay
will america erupt will we you know
bring
uh you know the sunshine on the us
congress
they hadn't by wednesday when these
stories came out voted they didn't vote
until i think thursday
or friday the stories had been out for
at least two days
and nothing happened i i will tell you
and this will get me in a little trouble
myself i have a friend deeply involved
in the national tea party movement
i called her and said jenny are you guys
going to expose this
and the reality is it didn't happen but
the answer is you have to
you have to get involved and you have to
expose it the congress voted on that and
then went home for a week recess
i know the tea party did some attempt to
hold them accountable
i would say to you don't be shy let me
tell you another story
i got deeply involved in the health care
reform issue
not because when i was a kid growing up
i cared about health care or health care
reform
as a matter of fact i hate hospitals and
i grew up saying i hate hospitals
but i was in a boy scout troop with two
guys
who happen to be become doctors one of
them was the son of a doctor and one
year older than me
the other one was became a doctor and he
was one year behind me
the fur the guy older than me taught me
how to tie a square knot and i taught
the guy below me how to tie a square
knot
and when i got elected to congress they
were not shy
they came to me and said john here's
what's happening in health care and they
taught me
what i would suggest you to try to give
you a practical suggestion
uh is do a little bit of thinking i have
a friend back in phoenix who has what he
who uses what he calls the
string theory he says john when you see
a problem you lower your head and go
straight into the wall
and you get wherever you get and he said
it's kind of a painful way to do it but
that's your approach he says to me
that's not the way i go at things i use
the string theory
and the string theory is to think about
the person you want to affect
and then think about somebody who knows
them and somebody who knows that guy
and somebody who knows that woman and
somebody who knows that woman and
someone who knows
the next guy all the way back until you
get somebody you know
and you you try to affect them by the
string theory what i would suggest you
is that everybody in this room
if you spend a little time thinking
about it know someone who knows someone
who knows someone
who is in a boy scout troop or a girl
scout troop or a kiwanis club
with your current congressman and you
need to figure that out
and you need to get in front of them and
when they vote for 38 billion dollars in
cuts
which turn out to be less than one
percent of that
they need to hear about it and and you
have to just go get in their face
and most of them i think today will take
a phone call and agree to a meeting with
any any legitimate tea party group or
group of uh citizens in their community
and it's just that simple you just got
to go do it you got to be informed and
you got to have the courage to go
confront them
yes ma'am would you say it's fair to
assume
that if this were not a career in other
words if there were term limits
that there would be no need for vote
buying or for going along to get along
the fact that it is a career is indeed a
serious issue having said that
i must confess to you i have mixed
emotions about whether term limits are
the right
correction um it is true
and it's the point i tried to make in my
remarks earlier when you
get elected as a freshman your goal
hopefully
is advance the constitution or advance
you know the
the nation do good for the nation you
discover
that well if i want to advance my career
then maybe that conflicts what's what
with what's good for the nation or maybe
it conflicts with what i told the people
back home
and that's the conflict i see in the
freshman class it's the conflict my
class
encountered with the old bulls of 1995.
and i think we need to institute things
to
hold career politicians in check but you
also remember that
my enumerated powers bill was killed not
by henry hyde
and not by charles kennedy it was killed
by a staffer
one of things you have to ask yourself
about term limits and some of my bright
friends back in arizona say
they could go along with term limits if
you term limited staff
as well uh which might indeed be what we
need to do
um i certainly think that the one of the
most corrupting
influences is uh you know the
uh the desire to advance your own career
and careerism people who stay forever
my friend tom coburn rails against
careerism and i think he's right about
it
i just don't know that term limits are
the best answer
i think a great answer is what happened
when we when we had the summer debates
on obamacare
and members got confronted by an engaged
and educated electorate that said
don't do this um unfortunately mrs
pelosi overboard their will
and as a result of that she lost the
majority and a and a huge number of
seats
my own personal view is that
holding members accountable is a better
device
if we do term limits i would like to see
us do them
with a fairly long period like 12 years
was talked about at one point in time
in arizona we've enacted term limits for
our state legislature and i do not
believe it has proven to be a good
reform
but i certainly think if we do term i'm
not willing to reject term limits
outright
but i think if we proceed down a course
of heading toward term limits
we need to be very thoughtful about it
in the arizona legislature we have very
short term limits
and people just bounce back and forth
from one house to the other but they
also
have no institutional memory so i would
watch the power of staff
staff already is extremely powerful
indeed one of the things you can ask is
if we have to hold the congress
accountable is the congress accepting
responsibility for its own conduct
even now or do they delegate it all to
staff members
one of the issues tarp tarp is one of
the most controversial votes that
occurred in my tenure in congress
and it was a stunning delegation of
power to other people that is a lack of
responsibility even by the current
members
i've watched some good people leave as a
result of term limits tom coburn left
as a result of a six-year term limit
imposed on him three-term term limit
six-year term
imposed on himself my friend matt salmon
left interestingly tom coburn came back
and became
you know one of the best united states
senators going in my book
interestingly matt salmon who also
self-terminated himself left after three
terms
is running again for the house this year
so uh certainly if we enact term limits
with the goal in mind of getting rid of
career politicians
we need to think about how we do it and
we need to think about and it must apply
to everyone
and we'd have to think about applying it
to staff as well our next question comes
from online
and mike from seattle washington asks
no one likes making hard decisions this
seems especially true for congress
when an issue seems too difficult they
often just punt their duty to the
supreme court
the constitution has suffered as a
result institutionally
how can we make congress want to reclaim
its authority from a majority
of five justices hmm wow
well both the congress and the court
uh have participated in
this erosion of limits of the
constitution
certainly the court has gone a long way
i would say right now
there's reason to be encouraged about
the court but the question was
how can we do that institutionally
i'm not certain i have a good answer for
that i think uh
obviously electing the right president
uh
and electing a senate that will use its
responsibilities appropriately
and if necessary not being afraid to
amend the constitution where we need to
amend the constitution
all of those are procedural devices that
we could use
one of the things that i worry about
every bit as much
as the threat imposed by congress
ignoring its responsibilities
and delegating power either to the
administration
as it did in tarp or passing vague
legislation and giving that authority to
the courts
and letting the courts decide what the
meaning of words is
is the uh willingness of congress to
allow
the i'm not the not willing willingness
of congress the willingness of us as a
people and the willingness of the states
to allow
the amassing of such immense power here
in washington
uh i would suggest the kind of the
challenge of today is not just to be
aware that the court
has excessive power but that we've moved
too much power out of the states and to
the federal government
i would suggest and it's a radical
notion but it ought to at least be on
the table
you know perhaps the founding fathers
had it right when they called for the
election the united states senators
by the state legislatures and not by
directly by the people
that is you know that's it that's a
constitutional amendment so it's
consistent with the constitution because
it was amended
but if you ask yourself for just a
moment would
a united states senator who had owed his
job
to the state legislature be willing to
participate in a process
which stole so much authority from the
state legislature
and gave it all to this massive central
government which
kind of seems not to care too much about
the states or their role in this process
so uh i think it's good that we're
debating those issues
i wish i had a more specific one of
course there are issues debating whether
or not we'll
ought to hold a constitutional
convention and we could get the room
quite excited about that but
other questions
i'm intrigued by your vision of asking
for
defining why it's part of the
constitution when they put forth a bill
and i'm curious what your vision would
be regarding the authorization of some
of these bills that the staffer was
referring to in particular i'll throw it
out if you want
sure the endangered species act which i
think involves taking
my view first of all i i think we need
this discussion
uh david bob and i have talked about the
fact you know it's easy to stand here
and say the founding fathers had a
better vision
and oh my gosh look how far we've
drifted from that how much power we've
moved out of the states and to the
federal government
and how much power we've granted the
federal government to do things that it
has
literally no authority whatsoever to do
um
in my class we talked about for example
repealing the federal department of
education
and of course we never got there when i
introduced the enumerated powers act
there there were various thoughts out
there
one was that you could not just require
them to cite
the provision of the constitution the
enumerated power that gave congress the
authority to do it
if they didn't do that you could not
allow the bill to be introduced or
you could have you could have a
procedure whereby it could be stricken
for that purpose
what i wanted to do was simply begin the
discussion
but as many of you know particularly
here at the kirby center
this has now begun a genuine debate
where members of congress today living
under the new house rule
are looking at an idea that a
constituent brought them
and saying well i want to introduce it
as a law my constituents like this idea
i think it's a good idea i want you to
introduce it their staff goes about the
task of drafting the bill and then says
to the congressman hey
what are we going to put down as the
constitutional justification and as
david will tell you the students here at
the kirby center are being asked to
draft justifications
and they're not taking it lightly
they're not just citing the general
welfare clause
and saying well that justifies
everything they are instead engaged in a
genuine debate is this legitimate
what i'd like to see happen is perhaps
somebody at the end of that debate
saying look we can't find a legitimate
justification
and then i'm looking for the member of
congress who picks up the phone and says
to the constituent you know we have this
new rule in congress it would be better
if it were a statute like i wanted it to
be
but we have this new rule in congress
that says i have to cite a provision of
the constitution that justifies the bill
you wanted me to drop
i think you have a great idea in this
bill but we can't find it anywhere like
davy crockett
we cannot find it anywhere in the
constitution as something that the
federal government is authorized to do
and therefore i've called state
legislator smith
and said that he asked him if he'd be
willing to drop this as a state statute
and i think you ought to go talk to him
and that would at least begin the
process
certainly there are many aspects of the
endangered species act which have
clearly resulted in
a taking and i think a more activist
property rights oriented supreme court
hopefully will someday
rule that much more often than it has so
far but i'd like to see that debate
begin even earlier
up my friend scott garrett from new
jersey wants a much more
vigorous version of the enumerated
powers act where if you can't prove
to the congress in debate that in point
of fact there is a legitimate
basis in the constitution for the
introduction of the bill or the passage
of the bill
or the assumption of that power by the
federal government it simply can't go
forward and there's a procedural rule
that would stop it
i'm all for it i just hope we can get
there in my lifetime
but i think your point is well taken i
think the debate is a part of the
process
but we would all acknowledge that uh
there are that the staffer who said to
me oh my gosh congressman
there are lots of things we're doing now
that for which there is no
constitutional justification
we all would acknowledge that that
staffer is right and that and that
that's why i said the beginning of our
remarks uh the job of holding
congress accountable to the constitution
uh is going to be a long
uh a long trail it took us uh 200 plus
years to get where we are
i hope it won't take us that long to get
back but at least we're having the
discussion
and at least organizations like the
kirby center and across the street
at the heritage foundation they're
looking at these kinds of issues
this will be our final question okay
since impala was clearly
unconstitutional
taking was there any challenge
at the time and
could it be challenged now by a hospital
which is forced to pay money would they
outstanding
it's a great question i'm actually very
glad you asked it um
here is the basis on which the congress
acted
the congress said we're going to compel
you to give free health care
at any hospital to anyone who presents
even without proof that they can pay the
bill and if they never pay the bill
uh and without citizenship that's right
in arizona and the
southwestern union sites uh we treat
lots of people who of course are not
citizens
um but what the congress said was you
only have to meet that requirement if
two things are true
one you have an emergency room
interestingly some hospitals across
america
are actually contemplating specialty
hospitals at least
simply doing away with their emergency
room because if you don't have an
emergency room
you don't come within the ambit of
impala but the real hook
on which the lower courts have held
it to not be not attacking are that it
is a condition
of medicare so if your hospital accepts
medicare
then you must give freemtala care now
the the argument under that goes well
you're not getting
you're not compelling them to give
something away for free because you're
letting them participate
in the medicare program and they get
profit out of the medicare program and
therefore it is a justifiable trade-off
the specific answer your question is
that the lower federal courts
i believe the fourth circuit and maybe
one or two
other circuits have heard this issue and
have sustained it on that basis
they have said yes you can condition
uh the res the participation in the
medicare program
on treating patients under amtala for
free
the problem with that is it's a little
bit like
what's the takings case that was debated
very
vigorously lately or recently kilo right
it's a little bit like the kilo case in
that there's
i think an issue of equities
if if you talk to a hospital in america
today most hospitals will tell
you if we did not participate in
medicare
which would get us out from amtala then
we could not survive as a hospital
because
medicare insures everyone in america all
the elderly in america
and without that patient base it's the
patients the elderly patients that use
hospitals
we simply couldn't exist i think a
careful examination would raise the
question of
well is it appropriate for the
government to say
you can condition medicare participation
in medicare on
accepting free patient uh or giving free
care under remtala
if there's no practical way in which the
hospitals could say no
and if alternatively you look at how
much money it's costing them
if they quite frankly they aren't making
much profit on medicare indeed
because the politicians promise all
these benefits under medicare and then
only pay for a fraction of them
these hospitals are arguably losing
money on medicare if you then turn
around and say
but they're they're making a little
money they may be losing it on the
margin and they may be cost shifting
from medicare
to their privately insured patients then
how do they pay for
the on the free care so-called free care
they give under amtala
and the answer is i think that's where
the taking occurs the
also the second answer your question is
since the issue has not been taken to
the united states supreme court
it could be taken to the supreme court
and i'd like to see i would hope
that some hospital or doctors group in
america will take it to the united
states supreme court
interestingly if you talk to people in
the medical practice you'll discover all
kinds of practical things have happened
when you ignore the constitution
one doctors feel like if they see a
patient
in a hospital emergency room and they
provide care to that patient because
for free because it's an amphtolo
patient that that patient then
if that patient then needs follow-up
care doctors are fearful not to give
that follow-up care in their
offices for free and that has caused a
great deal of concern
why they have not sued over that i don't
know except that the interesting
consequence is that there are a couple
of other consequences
one doctors used to give away i would
suggest by today's terms
billions if not trillions of dollars in
free care but you can imagine what
doctor says to himself today
well why should i be giving away free
care or what hospital says to itself
today
why should i be giving away free care
when the government has a gun at my head
saying i have to give away free care and
oh by the way
it's it's breaking me and that's what i
find so fascinating about the concession
by the lawyers in the federal case in
front of judge vincent in florida at
least
where it's been argued very clearly and
and you can see the arguments
but the federal lawyers are saying look
um
all these the decision by all of these
people not to buy health insurance
is causing massive health [ __ ] care cost
shifting
cost shifting to the insured people
therefore that impacts interstate
commerce and we can order some innocent
person
to go buy an insurance policy but it was
you the very government that caused the
cost shifting in the first place
by refusing to abide by the fifth
amendment the long story
the short answer to question is um the
constitution of amtala i don't know if
the specific
issue of the fifth amendment has been
raised i know that
the justification has been discussed in
cases the justification is
since you get well if you want to take
medicare patients and receive medicare
payments
you must provide free care under mtallah
it
what's important i think for us to
remember as a society
is we kind of think well that's the way
it always was but it isn't the way it
always was
when many of us in this room were kids
there was no amtala
people without money didn't go to
private hospitals people without money
went to the public hospital
they got care as we have a society have
decided they should
but we paid for it and i think we're
willing to pay for it i don't think
anybody in this debate is saying
we want people in this society to go
without care what we're saying is we
don't want the government taking our
freedom
to pick an insurance policy of our own
choice i hope that i hope somebody will
sue mtallah challenge it
constitutionally a doctor or a hospital
and say it is in fact and the courts
will ultimately conclude it is in fact
a taking under the fifth amendment thank
you so much i really have enjoyed this
thank you